in many ways the russian invasion of
ukraine felt all too familiar to the
people of taiwan
here is a larger more powerful
authoritarian and revisionist bully
attacking its democratic neighbor for
nothing more than historical proximity
and beneath a mountain of explanations
theories and models is really just one
man's deranged pursuit of empire
or something else entirely we truly
don't know
it even began like we expect an attack
on taiwan would with a long drawn-out
build-up of forces followed by a sudden
and chaotic barrage of missiles
with very large present populations but
below replacement fertility both china
and russia are what you might call
demographies in decline and there isn't
much time left
a man born today can expect to live 74
years in china and a mere 67 in russia
ukraine today taiwan tomorrow isn't just
hypothetical either
quote reunifying with the island has
been the goal of every chinese leader
for the last 70 years and chairman xi
jinping has gone well out of his way to
eliminate ambiguity
needless to say china's refusal to call
russia's actions in ukraine what they
are an invasion wasn't too comforting to
the 23 million residents of taiwan
yet china is not russia and taiwan is
not ukraine
for all their similarities there remain
huge differences the world would be
unwise to ignore
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch my new original
series
the second episode out now is about why
china is still 900 days later trying to
maintain zero cases of kovid despite the
enormous cost and complete disaster that
was the shanghai lockdown
you can watch it in the first episode
about how chinese censorship works and
all future episodes with the curiosity
stream and nebula bundle which is just
12 a year right now in the us for
memorial day
just 100 miles or 160 kilometers east
across the narrow taiwan strait you
could be forgiven for thinking china
could one day just swallow up its little
disconnected tail
russia has three times the population of
ukraine
china 60 times more than taiwan
the russian economy is or more
accurately was nine and a half times
larger than ukraine's
china's is 22 times the size of taiwan's
the russian land mass is 28 times larger
than ukraine's
and china's
265 times larger than taiwan's
in 2020 china spent 244 billion dollars
on defense
taiwan just 11 about as much as the
netherlands or colombia
of course as the american navy
demonstrates not every dollar spent on
defense is created equally
still the disparities are quite dramatic
china has upwards of 2 million active
duty troops 3 300 fighters and 59 subs
to taiwan's 160
560 and 4.
in other words china is probably every
bit as big strong and powerful as it
looks
and yet ask just about anyone in the
defense community and they'll tell you a
chinese invasion of taiwan would be just
downright hard
now there are many different ways china
could go about this by launching a cuba
style blockade by first seizing smaller
islands on its periphery or even
infiltrating from within
but the most likely sequence of events
would be as follows
first china would start bombing critical
taiwanese infrastructure ports airports
and bases in hopes of causing chaos
confusion and a breakdown in the chain
of command
second china would attempt to establish
air superiority control of the skies and
therefore cover for what comes next
as we've seen in ukraine this is much
harder than it sounds even for an
ostensibly larger and more powerful
attacker
still up to this point there's no doubt
china could at the very least quickly
inflict serious and irreparable harm
this next phase is when the people's
liberation army likely runs into trouble
as anyone who's seen saving private ryan
can attest amphibious assaults are no
walk in the park even on the best of
days
generally speaking to be successful they
require three conditions
air superiority overwhelming fire and
manpower or surprise
and the ability to quickly reinforce
every battle is different of course but
historical successes have with few
exceptions possessed all three criteria
in the vast majority of cases the
absence of even one of these has led to
failure
if everything goes as planned for china
it will have accomplished the first but
that still leaves two very difficult
hurdles which brings us to the real
challenge
russia's struggles so far in ukraine
make it easy to lose sight of the basics
this is not with one major exception a
geographically challenging
environment when you come across
pictures of the war make a note of what
you see
roads and what you don't
mountains
we're used to seeing russia's invasion
on a map but this is what it looks like
on the ground what geographers would
call flat eurasian step
the biggest natural impediments are
trees grass and tractors
the coast of taiwan on the other hand is
much trickier sure there are flat mud
planes and coastal rice patties but any
invader would soon be met with two and
three thousand foot peaks within
artillery distance of the shoreline
in between are fairly populous urban
areas
take the usual defender's advantage two
or three attackers per defending troop
and thanks to taiwan's tall and
irregular coastline multiply it several
times over
if that sounds hard well the world's
most powerful military agreed
the united states considered attacking
then-japanese-occupied taiwan in 1944
going so far as to draft plans for
operation causeway
overtaking a patchwork of thirty
thousand starving japanese defenders it
estimated would require an invasion
force over twice the size of d-day four
hundred thousand marines and 4 000 ships
despite commanding this incredible
concentration of force pacific war
planners considered the idea too risky
and opted for the philippines instead
referring to taiwan as an unsinkable
aircraft carrier
suffice to say china would need a
figurative boatload of troops somewhere
between 1 and 2 million to be precise
making it the largest amphibious
operation in history
if war is primarily an exercise in
logistics this would be the ultimate
challenge
moving that many bodies simultaneously
is no easy feat
take a simple back of the envelope
calculation for instance
assuming china was using that same 2020
equipment from earlier this is all it
could transport across the strait at a
time
even if all it transported were troops
it could only move about thirty thousand
or three percent of the total number of
active pla ground forces at a time
and remember that's if they just carried
people with no tanks or armor
for obvious reasons this hypothetical
operation has been nicknamed the million
man swim
oh and by the way nothing about this
would be a secret
experts estimate the world will have no
fewer than 30 and up to 60 days of
warning giving taiwan a full one to two
months to make itself as impenetrable as
possible laying mines staging weapons
and repositioning critical
infrastructure
not only that but we also already know
during which parts of the year china
could attack
waves are too strong in the winter and
typhoons too unpredictable in the summer
leaving just two good candidates april
or october
so too do we know where it would happen
there are only about 13 beaches across
all of taiwan suitable for landing and
suitable is being generous
take one of these lincol beach for
instance
although invaders would be welcomed by
about a mile of flat land they would
soon be confronted by two huge mountain
ranges
this would also be the pla soldiers and
generals first real experience with
combat
china hasn't fought a single major war
for over 40 years when it invaded
vietnam and was quickly forced to
withdraw
now even if it was successful china
would now face a new challenge
occupying an island of 23 million people
most of whom hate it with much of what
it considers valuable about taiwan
utterly destroyed
military doctrines suggest a one to ten
ratio of soldiers to population for
successful counter-insurgency operations
which on paper would require the entire
pla leaving no one for anything else
as we see in ukraine
local resistance can be incredibly
powerful
especially given that taiwan has been
preparing for its entire modern
existence for precisely this scenario
in one 2020 poll 77 of the taiwanese
public said they were willing to fight
for their country
still it should be noted that at least
today conscription only lasts four
months in taiwan
how much can one really do or learn in
120 days
and in general conscription armies are
less competent and more apathetic
but don't get too lost in the weeds
asking whether china can attack before
asking if it will
balance of strength is important but
it's far from the whole picture
any theory about what china wants or how
it thinks has to contend with two
seemingly contradictory facts
on one hand china has been beating the
drama of war for seven decades making
countless explicit threats and seemingly
preparing its population for conflict
like north korea and missiles the issue
seems to percolate to the surface
several times a year
each time feels like a crisis
yet on the other hand china has been
beating the drum of war for seven
decades and has never once actually
followed through no matter your
political affiliations you can't say
china hasn't had the full range of
american administrations to choose from
the funny thing is that look at a graph
of google searches for headlines related
to war between taiwan and china and a
clear pattern emerges
panic at least by this metric is a
relatively recent and uniquely english
phenomenon
searches in traditional chinese used in
taiwan have been pretty much steady for
as long as the graph goes back
likewise when chinese jets make mock
attack runs toward taiwan it's very
often the american not taiwanese public
who panics
so what do calmer minds know that the
rest of us don't
in democracies like the u.s it's often
said that each party needs the other
that if one party were ever given too
much power for too long it would be
forced to deliver on its promises many
of which it never intended to
it would have no excuse no scapegoat to
blame when it failed
a similar dynamic plays out in
autocracies like china
the enemy in this case is not the
opposing party there are none but some
manufactured national humiliation
remember taiwan the island was never
ruled by the communist party
the framing of taiwan as a source of
shame for china that it can only ever be
complete after quote reunification is
entirely artificial
china in other words willfully chose
this version of history
and its predictable effects give us a
hint as to why
chinese citizens are regularly told
their country could easily take taiwan
in a day
constantly reminded that they personally
are being transgressed upon when
american carrier groups sail through the
taiwan strait
chinese artists render video game-like
scenes of valiant chinese soldiers
roaming the streets of taipei
this mix of shame patriotism and thirst
for conquest makes a large number of
chinese citizens love the party just
that much more
one can't help but wonder
given what an invasion would entail is
taiwan more useful to the chinese
leadership as a perpetually imminent
national rejuvenation
a button in simplistic terms chinese
authorities can press whenever things
aren't going particularly well at home
not only to distract but more
importantly to stoke nationalism
this does not however rule out an
invasion
the danger for china is that it can
easily become dependent on this button
each time china gains short-term
domestic approval for threatening taiwan
or making outlandish claims about how
easy an invasion would be
it is in effect writing a check that
would be extraordinarily costly to cash
yet it has created conditions under
which it may feel forced to
if for example taiwan were to formally
declare independence or if it faced a
legitimacy crisis at home
and ultimately predictions can only get
us so far
one of the principal lessons so far from
the war in ukraine is not that the
experts were wrong exactly but that
rational models of how humans should
behave don't always match reality
we can only see the world as it is not
as putin or xi jinping see it
russia will pay an enormous economic
cost for its actions
it has already been reduced on the world
stage to the status of north korea
but although these sanctions may slow
its efforts they have not dissuaded them
while the odds of a chinese invasion of
taiwan may appear slim on paper we
cannot proceed under that assumption
in no small part because the world's
vigilance is itself one of the things
that may dissuade china by taking the
possibility seriously we may make it
less likely
the status quo is ideal for no one
china will forever see taiwan as a
renegade province a piece of unfinished
business from its past
many in the united states are likewise
angry that we have to tiptoe around the
issue so as not to upset a bully
and of course the people of taiwan face
the biggest burden of all being denied
the privileges safety and opportunities
of widely recognized statehood
but at least for now all three parties
have seemingly and for vastly different
reasons decided the status quo is still
better than the alternative
still predicting china's actions is hard
in fact currently harder than it has
been for decades as it remains
effectively cut off from the rest of the
world thanks to its extremely
heavy-handed coveted restrictions
china is so cut off from the outside
world that it's now banning quote
unnecessary travel preventing many of
its own citizens even students studying
abroad from leaving
almost no one expects china to open up
again anytime soon
why
that's a question that's been on my mind
for a long time and one i tried to
tackle in the second episode of my new
nebula original series
some argue it's about the economy others
say it's more about presenting an image
of china abroad
but none of these theories quite capture
the craziness we've seen in shanghai
live fish tested for kovid investment
bankers left starving in their homes and
all manner of things in between
you can watch this along with the first
episode of the series plus all my normal
videos add free and other great nebula
originals and get access to curiosity
stream right now for just 12 a year in
the us for memorial day
on curiosity stream you'll find great
feature-length documentaries like this
investigation into a dangerous secretive
ukrainian city completely cut off from
the rest of the world
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
an amazing 12 bucks a year and go watch
my original series over on nebula